so here we have our function in name it
takes in a parameter called name so when
we take a name we want to call trim
which removes the whitespace from the
front and the back of that string so our
string currently will look something
like this we can see that this string
doesn't have any differentiation between
the first name and the last name so we
have to call a function called splits
and we pass in the character or string
that we want to split the source string
from so in this case it's a space which
occurs here between Sebastian and throne
now when we call split it returns an
array of Sebastian and threaten our next
line here prints out that to the console
this next line named one equals name one
to uppercase changes our last name to
totally uppercase so in this array down
here we have name zero and we have name
one which has been turned into totally
uppercase this next line is a little bit
tricky let's take a piece by piece
name zero dot slash to uppercase the
dots slice function takes in two
parameters of where to start and where
to end in a string and creates a
substring so for this one in name zero
right here it's starting at position
zero it's converting that to uppercase
which it already was but our function
doesn't have a way of knowing that
and then it appends it to the slice
starting at position one and converting
that string to lowercase if you don't
pass in a second parameter it goes to
the end of the string so looking at this
example again we'll start at position
one and go all the way to the end where
the n is so our last line takes those
two values and appends them together it
returns it as a string and our string
becomes all done